ladies and gentlemen it has happened we
have the movies w we have JFK we have
Nixon now we have Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter ha ha ha that's right
that's why I have this I was shaving for
this video I was like app this is about
Abraham Lincoln I'm keeping this
probably can't even see it on this
camera it took me like a month to grow
this puberty was not kind yes there is a
movie called Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter coming out and is as you would
think
apparently Abraham Lincoln was secretly
a vampire hunter and effort some mixed
feelings about this some people like to
do this the stupidest premise ever
I agree the movie could be stupid I also
agree it could be so awesome my voice
even cracked it's that cool Abraham
Lincoln was one of the greatest
presidents we've ever had how do you
make one of the greatest presidents ever
better all Yeats make him a vampire
hunter you have instantly made one of
the coolest men ever a little cooler
look at that guy he's a badass some
people are betting now they're like oh
would Snooks George Washington's zombie
hunter Oh what's next Teddy Roosevelt
Bigfoot hunter I hope so cuz I would
watch those two because those sound
awesome also I mean it's Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter it's supposed to be out
of this world kind of you know that
would that didn't happen it's not like
they made a movie that's truly just out
there like a movie called Barack Obama I
lived up to the hype or George W Bush
vs. Ernie's magic shapes or anything
absurd like that that's when I'd be like
I can deal with Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter but those other two come on
that's just being crazy I agree there
are scenes in this movie where you're
like that could be cool that could be
like Jonah Hex I hope it's not like
Jonah Hex I hope this isn't like sucker
punch when I said sucker punch looked
cool and then I saw sucker punch and
felt like an [ __ ] yeah that would be
bad I hope it's not like that in the end
Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter absurd
yes crazy absolutely entertaining
probably this looks like the kind of
movie if you've ever found amusement or
joy in a chuck norris joke you might be
able to like this movie what it seems
like anyway so the trailer - Abraham
Lincoln vampire hunter have you seen it
what did you think of it comment below
let me know and today is the day part
one of the year reviewers movie awards
is going to be uploaded on ENTV today
when it's uploaded I'll put an
annotation right there just click on it
it'll take you right to it or I'll put a
link below in the description you can
click on that - if you can't click on
that yet check back it's coming this is
your guys's show so I hope you enjoy it
in any case if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more